era il 1966 e il genio visionario di una
persona incredibile isaac asimov aveva
raccontato a tutti noi o la storia
incredibile di quattro scienziati che
erano stati miniaturizzati alle
dimensioni di una cellula iniettati
all'interno del circolo sanguigno di un
paziente per trovare le ragioni di una
malattia e curarlo beh sono passati
esattamente 50 anni da quel film è
quello scenario fantascientifico oggi è
diventato realtà e rifaremo insieme
quello stesso viaggio
entreremo all'interno del nostro corpo
scopriremo come le cellule riparano i
tessuti incontreremo il sistema
immunitario
cercheremo di capire come le cellule
comunicano tra di loro e arriveremo alla
fine fino alla nano sfera dove nuove
incredibili tecnologie stanno cambiando
il modo di curare i tumori è tutto in 15
minuti per garantisco la storia inizia
qui da un dito quanti di voi si sono mai
tagliati un dito e quanti hanno pensato
ma qua ci vogliono i punti qua tutti
coraggiosi come me è in realtà la
maggior parte delle volte non servono i
punti perché il corpo sa esattamente
cosa fare per fermare il sangue e
riparare la ferita è il laboratorio ci
siamo presi la briga di andare a vedere
cosa succede con un microscopio guardate
quello che succede nel vaso sanguigno
quella striscia rossa
vedrete le cellule che sfrecciano a
tutta manetta anche se in realtà c'era
un problema la ferita nessuno se ne cura
fino a quando un certo punto viene dato
il segnale e da lì le cellule iniziano
ad andare a tutta forza verso la sede
della ferita cercano di ripararla
cercano di depositare nuovo materiale
cercano di rimediare alla situazione e
questo continua fino a quando la
costante e coordinata proliferazione
delle cellule richiude i due lembi della
ferita
riportando tutto all'ordine questo non
succede però solamente in caso di una
ferita 200 milioni sono il numero di
cellule che sono morte in ciascuno di
voi da quando ho iniziato a parlare ecco
spero non dalla noia è comunque sicuro
non è colpa mia perché questo è un
processo che succede 24 ore su 24 300
miliardi di cellule che ogni giorno il
vostro organismo deve ricreare in modo
tale da mantenere tutto in funzione un
sacco di lavoro e guardate le queste
sono delle cellule che si rendono conto
che c'è dello spazio libero ecco come
fare iniziano a replicare dividersi quei
piccoli lampi di luce si sgomitano si
fanno spazio cercano in tutti i modi di
risolvere il problema è meno piano ce la
fanno
fino a quando finalmente arriva il
segnale di stop ci si può riposare
a volte però le cellule se ne
infischiano del segnale di stop e quello
che succede nel caso dei tumori e questa
è una cosa che riguarda un po tutti noi
perché nell'arco della nostra vita tutti
sviluppiamo almeno un 10 principi di
tumore adesso non vi allarmate perché le
stesse cellule di prima le cellule del
sistema immunitario
intervengono a risolvere la situazione e
vele voglio presenta da vicino perché
sono degli eroi silenziosi senza i quali
andremo veramente nei guai sono quelli
specie di fantasmini verdi che vedete
riconosco in maniera selettiva le
cellule rosse del tumore e guardate una
volta che l'hanno riconosciuto e non la
mollano più sembrano quasi ingaggiarla
in un tango forse è meglio dirlo una una
lotta sembrano delle scene di caccia di
da un pianeta alieno e spesso la cellula
non ce la fa da sola e allora cosa fa
chiama rinforzi e qui vediamo una
cellula tumorale al centro in blu che ha
chiamato altre due cellule guardate quei
pallini rossi quello è la l'enzima
litico che ucciderà alla fine la cellula
tumorale e quella lo vedete in azione la
cellule immunitarie si avvicina inietta
fisicamente quell enzima e fa esplodere
la cellula tumorale
pericolo scampato grazie sistema
immunitario
un'altra cosa che volevo dire che è
veramente la meraviglia di tutti i video
che avete visti che avete visto è che
per registrarli non ho mai dovuto
aggiungere nessun farmaco le cellule
sanno esattamente quello che fare
sono programmate si parlano si
coordinano identificano il problema sono
un po una specie di mister wolf di pulp
fiction semi consegnatemi esatto
sembrano consiglieri non lasciate dire
eh no
il problema è che però ci ammaliamo
perché non sempre il sistema immunitario
riesce a far fronte alla al tumore e
grazie a dio medici e chirurghi salvano
la vita di milioni di pazienti che
altrimenti non avrebbero speranza con
centinaia di terapie e farmaci che però
hanno tutti un aspetto comune mirano
tutti alla distruzione diretta del
problema una specie di attacco frontale
una versione terapeutica del desert
storm che non guarda in faccia niente
nessuno qui la buttano un po in ridere
però la verità è che ci sono delle nuove
forme di armi di distruzione di massa
che usano i medici sono i chemioterapici
e non è certo colpa dei medici il colpa
che il corpo funziona in un modo
incredibile quando iniettiamo un farmaco
in quella molecole rosse dentro la
siringa per trattare un tumore per
esempio al fegato
quello che vorremmo è che arrivasse solo
fegato ma dopo l'iniezione il sangue lo
porta a tutte le cellule anche a quelle
che non serve e questo credo gli effetti
collaterali possiamo fare meglio di
questo quello che vogliamo è quello che
vi ho detto prima iniettare in una vena
e far arrivare il farmaco solamente al
tumore
quello che serve dare al farlo con la
specie di gps capace di navigarlo
all'interno di 100.000 km di vasi
sanguigni così tanti ne avete ciascuno
di voi ne il proprio corpo 100.000 km
diversi sanguigni sani a cui il farmaco
non serve per andare a trovare invece
questi vasi sanguigni che sembrano molto
diversi
e sono quelli che invece irrorano il
tumore è quello che vi racconta oggi
alla storia della mia carriera
scientifica 20 anni passati a cercare di
risolvere questo problema come far
arrivare il farmaco solo al tumore e
questo viaggio inizia con la mia grossa
passione quella che avevo da bambino di
diventare un biologo molecolare non so
quanti vogliono ai calciatori io volevo
fare il biologo molecolare e cerco di
imparare tutto quello che posso su
cellule impara scopro che sono in
costante comunicazione tra di loro si
parlano si aggiornano sul loro stato di
salute e su quello del micro ambiente
che le circonda lo fanno in maniera
diversa da quella che fa che usiamo noi
usando gli esosomi una parola un po
complicata noi scienziati ci piace che
però sentirete in futuro molto spesso
questi esosomi non sono altro che delle
piccole vescicole che la cellula secerne
incostante costantemente le manda poi in
circolo le affida al sangue e in qualche
modo in modo in realtà che ancora non
capiamo esattamente queste stesse
vescicole riescano a trovare la cellula
bersaglio in questo caso una cellula di
tumore che abbiamo colorato in verde nei
video che abbiamo fatto vedere prima non
avevamo dei microscopi abbastanza
potenti ma se andiamo a vedere cosa
succede quando la cellula trova il
tumore quando la cellula riparo una
ferita quando decide di rigenerarsi
quello che succede che è in costante
produzione la costante produzione di
questi esosomi e vedete la scala ho
messo scale per farvi capire a che a che
punto dello spazio siamo sono 100
nanometri mille volte più piccolo di un
vostro capello
eppure guardate quanta complessità la
cellula in 100 nanometri proteine che
decorano la superficie contenuti
molecolari che danno informazione questo
è quello che serve imparare l'esoso ma
va in circolo in qualche modo trova la
cellula bersaglio si lega un recettore
specifico quello rosso
non quello verde quello blu quello rosso
trasmette il segnale all'interno della
cellula raggiunge un effetto re che fa
cambiare comportamento alla cellula
ma se ci pensate questo è esattamente
quello che vorremmo fare con il farmaco
cambiamo esosomi drag farmaco farlo che
iniettato in circolo
arriva la cellula bersaglio lega quel
recettore specifico che in questo caso
dovrebbe tradurre il segnale è uccidere
la cellula
questo è quello che volevamo fare e per
farlo serviva quella specie di arma
segreta quella oggetto di fantascienza
anni sessanta o esattamente l'esoso ma
quello che la cellula fa tutti i giorni
e per imparare a fare queste strutture
così piccole mi serviva andare via da
dove ero e fare l'emigrante io so quello
al centro pieno d'entusiasmo son
vecchiato e vado a huston ha sede del
più grande centro medico del mondo tutti
quei grattacieli che vedete in primo
piano ognuno di quelli a un ospedale
università un centro di ricerca più di
100.000 persone che lavorano
quotidianamente alla risoluzione di
problemi al momento problemi di salute
al momento incurabile e lì per un nerd
come me è il sogno di una vita
trovo il modo di aprire diversi
laboratori
scelgo persone giovanissime mi piace
trovarli pieni di entusiasmo senza
preconcetti sulla scienza in modo tale
da creare senza nessun confine sono
giovani ma sono preparati e vengono da
un background culturale molto diverso ci
sono fisici ingegneri chimici
pharmacology biologi medici e ai serviva
tutto questo per riuscire a risolvere il
problema ma siccome ci piaceva alla
diversità
avevamo deciso anche di andarci a
prendere un po da tutte le parti del
mondo una specie di nazioni unite della
scienza dove tutte le diversità
rivenivano annientate dal fatto che
avevamo tutti un obiettivo comune
inventare il modo per sviluppare
nanofarmaci e questa non alcune delle
nanoparticelle che avevamo fatto
immaginate ogni colore e un tipo diverso
di farmaco ogni forma e dimensione un
diverso target terapeutico e negli anni
abbiamo sviluppato tante di queste e
pubblicate in alcuni dei migliori
riviste al mondo ricordando però quello
che era la mia passione la biologia e
mantenendo una legge generale quello che
avevo consigliato di fare ai miei
ragazzi era di usare un principio il
principio della biomimetica
l'osservazione della natura per la
risoluzione dei nostri problemi
cercare di osservare un fenomeno
imparare qualcosa ed applicarlo alle
tecnologie che stavamo sviluppando e qui
è quando nella storia tutti i nostri
player tutti i nostri personaggi
arrivano insieme abbiamo sviluppato la
nanoparticella l'abbiamo caricata del
farmaco rosso di prima
l'abbiamo iniettata in circolo vediamo
adesso dentro il capillare tutte queste
nanoparticelle che vanno ma c'è un
problema il sistema immunitario in
questo caso funziona da cellula
vigilantes per lui
le nanoparticelle sono degli esseri
estranei al corpo e come tale
potenzialmente dannosi da eliminare e
quindi li vedete che queste le cellule
cessione immunitario come dei pac man
vanno a mangiarsi tutte le particelle la
vedrete adesso una chebanca la mette
dentro
fine della storia per il farmaco è anche
se queste cellule erano bellissime da
vedere in azione mentre si andavano ad
acchiappare le particelle essere
mangiavano questo era un problema vero
da un punto di vista clinico perché le
particelle non riuscivano più arrivare
in numero sufficiente al tumore
guardando questo fenomeno e ricordandomi
dei principi della biomimetica a me
sembrava di vedere una scena nota fasi
la scena di una preda è un predatore la
preda avviene acchiappata dal predatore
proprio con delle manine quella alla
superficie di una cellula che
afferra una nanoparticella la inizia a
portare piano piano dentro di sé se la
mangia la cellula mangia la particella
come il predatore mangia la preda
eppure natura ogni tanto la preda riesce
a scappare perché si mimetizza usa il
camouflage
e allora ho detto ma forse se noi
riusciamo a mimetizzare le
nanoparticelle a vestirle da cellule del
sistema immunitario gli facciamo mettere
la loro divisa da vigilantes forse
quello riuscirà a salvare le
nanoparticelle e così abbiamo fatto
facile a dirsi ci abbiamo messo
centinaia di ottimizzazioni che è il
modo in cui gli ingegneri definiscono i
fallimenti fondamentalmente
ottimizzazioni è però la cosa
incredibile è che siamo riusciti a
mimetizzare queste particelle vestendole
da cellula quelle erano le stesse
cellule immunitarie di prima quelle che
si mangiavano le particelle in questo
caso le particelle stanno lì seduto
comodamente sopra le sembrano quasi
parlarsi
ma questo ci aveva reso un po azzardati
nei nostri gol ha detto se riusciamo a
imitare la membrana di una cellula per
mimetizzare una nanoparticella forse
possiamo anche copiare gli esosomi
quelle strutture che la cellula usa per
parlare
possiamo forse riuscire a creare una
specie di nuovo alfabeto sintetico che
ci permetterebbe di metterci in contatto
con le cellule che così dopo altri 3 4
anni di studi siamo riusciti a fare i
nostri esosomi sintetici l'abbiamo
appena pubblicato sembrano abbastanza
simili no che ne dite
anche queste sono sferiche anche queste
sono mille volte più piccole della
sezione di un capello anche quest'anno
tutta quella complessità in superficie e
quella ricchezza di messaggi all'interno
e dovendo scegliere qual era la prima
nanoparticella da creare io ho deciso di
copiare quella che permette a un farmaco
di arrivare selettivamente al tumore e
in quest ultimo video vedrete
questo è un tumore un modello pre
clinico di tumore al seno iniettiamo un
farmaco libero quelle specie di molecole
nei verdi alcune arrivano si fermano la
maggior parte è andata via subito dopo
iniziamo il nostro esodò ma sintetico in
fucsia e vedete come arriva in maniera
selettiva si lega alle cellule è quello
che fa di natura e non va più via
questo ci permette adesso di avere tutto
il tempo per comunicare il messaggio
alle cellule di tumore e questo anche
un'altra aspetto ancora più profondo
secondo me perché ci permette di
riconsiderare in maniera drastica il
modo in cui facciamo medicina potendo un
giorno decidere di mandare un messaggio
ad una popolazione particolare di
cellule cosa decideremo di fare
decideremo di mandare ancora un
messaggio tossico alle cellule di tumore
o decideremo di mandare un messaggio di
attivazione alle cellule del sistema
immunitario
beh i laboratori di tutto il mondo
iniziano ad aprirsi alla seconda di
possibilità e tre anni fa sono stati
introdotti in clinica le prime e
protocolli di immunoterapia non più
farmaci non più sostanze tossiche ma il
sistema immunitario
i ragazzi fantasmini di prima che
riescano in qualche modo individuare il
tumore a sconfiggerlo
adesso io sono uno scienziato e quindi
di natura sono un inguaribile ottimista
perché so che il futuro ci riserva
scoperte incredibili e non sarei affatto
sorpreso se in un futuro molto prossimo
scopriremo che per curare il tumore
forse a volte la cosa migliore non sarà
di attaccarlo frontalmente ma di aiutare
il corpo a risolverlo da solo
grazie